Hello and welcome to the second lecture on
the binomial theorem.
In this lecture, we will look at the binomial
theorem and some of the related results which
can be derived from the binomial theorem.
First, recall the definition of nC_r, which
is the number of ways of choosing r objects
from n distinct objects, and which can be
written as n!/[(n-r)!
* r!].
So the binomial theorem
given by this result:
(x+y)^n = nC_0 x^n y^0 + nC_1 x^ y^1
+ ... + nC_ x^1 y^ + nC_n x^0 y^n,
where nC_r is the number of ways of choosing
r objects from n distinct objects. This can
be more succinctly written as the summation
\sum_^ y^r}.
The binomial theorem can be taken to be an
identity in x and y. The binomial theorem
is applicable for x and y complex, and n being
a positive integer.
At this point, I would like to mention that
generalizations of the binomial theorem for
the case when n is any real number also exist.
In the definition/in the expression of the
binomial theorem, we take x^0 to be equal
to 1 for all x which are complex numbers,
i.e., irrespective of the value of x, we define
x^0 to be equal to 1.
Notice that there are n+1 terms in the binomial
theorem, and there are NOT n terms but n+1
terms in the binomial theorem. You notice
that there is a sort of pattern to the terms
in the binomial theorem, and that is well
captured by the general term of the binomial
theorem. In general, the (r+1)th term in the
expansion of (x+y)^n can be written as nC_r
x^ y^r.
To
give you an example of the application of
the binomial theorem, let's look at (x+y)^1.
From the binomial theorem, we get that this
is nothing but 1C_0 x^1 y^0 + 1C_1 x^0 y^1
which gives us x+y, which is what we expect.
We can also derive for the case when we have
(x+y)^2, which is nothing but 2C_0 x^2 y^0
+ 2C_1 x^1 y^1 + 2C_2 x^0 y^2. Since 2C_0
is 1, we have x^2; 2C_1 is nothing but 2,
we have 2xy; and 2C_2 is again 1 so we have
y^2. This is the well known result (x+y)^2
= x^2 + 2xy + y^2.
Similarly, you can derive that (x+y)^3 is
x^3 + 3x^2 y + 3x y^2 + y^3, and you can derive
this result from the binomial expansion as
well.
So one way in which you can interpret the
binomial theorem is as follows: to derive
(x+y)^n is equal to this expression, just
consider (x+y)^n as nothing but (x+y)*(x+y)*...*(x+y)
for a total of n terms, and the interpretation
of this expansion can be given as follows.
If you choose n x's, then you choose an x
from each of these, uh, each of these parentheses
here, and so there is only one way of choosing
x's from each of these parentheses. There
is only one way of choosing n x's and 0 y's,
and that gives you the coefficient of x^n
y^0. If you want to choose (n-1) x's from
this expression, then you have to choose (n-1)
x's from the n possible x's, and you have
to choose 1 y from the n possible y's, and
that can be done in n choose 1 ways, and that
gives you the coefficient of x^ y^1 (and
so on).
In this way, you can derive the/you can provide
a combinatorial interpretation of the binomial
expansion.
So, as I mentioned previously, there are generalizations
for the binomial theorem for the case when
this exponent n is not necessarily a positive
integer, but when it can be any real number.
This is the general result of the binomial
theorem, and you can derive several related
results by playing around with the general
result of the binomial theorem. For instance,
you could replace y by -y in the theorem and,
upon doing so, you would get an expression
for (x-y)^n. This is going to be nC_0 x^n
(-y)^0 + nC_1 x^ (-y)^1 + ... + nC_n
x^0 (-y)^n, and
this can be more simply written as summation
\sum_^ y^r}. This
result is very similar to the result we derived
for the binomial theorem.
A second result which we can derive is by
replacing y by 1, in which case we can derive
an expansion for (x+1)^n as nC_0 x^n 1^0 +
nC_1 x^ 1^1 + ... + nC_n x^0 1^n. This
can be written as nC_0 x^n + nC_1 x^
+ ... + nC_n x^0. Now, to arrive at a more
simpler expression of this result, use the
fact that nC_r is nC_ and you can derive
this to be equal to nC_n x^n + nC_ x^
+ ... + nC_0 x^0. This
last expression can simply be written as summation
\sum_^. This is the binomial
expansion of (x+1)^n.
Similarly, we can also derive this result
from the binomial expansion: we can derive
an expansion for (x+y)^n + (x-y)^n. If you
apply the binomial expansion for these two
separate expressions, you will get 2*[nC_0
x^n y^0 + nC_2 x^ y^2 + ...]. The
alternate terms will cancel out and it will
leave you with this result.
So that's it for this lecture. Hope you had
fun listening to the binomial theorem and
some of its related results. In the next lecture,
we will be looking at some examples of the
usage of the binomial theorem and some possible
problems you will face in an exam situation.
Thank you.